Uuuuu do
[Music]
web advertisement
I had
[Music]
voodoo
lab n
voodoo Yeah yeah yeah [Music] Hmm [Music]
Drowning of the Hyrule Kingdom Even if I
go from ancient times, it's a sign called Ghan
What happened
to 100 people
?
[Music]
[Music] From
here until 22:50 Tokyo Game Show 2020 Hyrule Warriors
Apocalypse Special Live Broadcast  I'm Ruriko Aoki, who will be the mc.
Thank you.
[Applause]
I'm also a fan of the tab series, so today I'm thinking of doing it from the same perspective as everyone
else, but I said in a meeting ahead of that.  I was told
that there are times when I can't answer what I said
.
Yes, please help Hayashi, the producer of Koei Tekumo Games.
[Applause]
And I'm Ryo Matsushita, the director of Koei Tekumo Games
.
[Applause]
We welcome these two people to the program.
Just the other day, yes, the release of the Hyrule Warriors Apocalypse was announced, but
yes, it
's a story that received the feedback of all the users.
I wish everyone was surprised even if it was a tear surprise delivered to everyone at Pra Izu. It
's Hyrule Warriors before the range. Because it's that festival title,
various characters came out from various series every term.  It
was a title like a lot of Rin on the morning of the festival, but as I announced this time
, the apocalypse of the 0 Arms disaster is that press of the
development team of Nintendo.  We've been developing this kind of game after receiving a lot of talk from everyone, so if you want to make a game like this on your
own,
or if you want to make a game like this on your own, various
characters are ideal.
Because it ’s an all-star game  This time with the people of that breath team
Patty I was able to announce this time and it's very yeah yeah yeah yeah I took it with me and it's
quite true the night before
.  But it's the same right in the middle.
It was strange even if I made it slowly and together
. What am I doing? I was making it while I wasn't
like Chan yet.
There are a lot of amazing users, and that many
people are looking forward to it again. I'm sorry I realized that Patty is
serious.  Although it is an apocalypse
, I would like to review what kind of game it is again. Please introduce Mr. Hafenko.
Yes
, please
see here. The apocalypse when burning Dams is the
legend of Zelda Breath Oza Wild  Actually y It is
a title that you can experience the unknown history there with a title that focused on this when you were a substitute 100 years ago who did not
break up directly.
Yes, the major world view is as you saw in the video above
. Now, the breath of world is inherited, and the
fragmentary drawing of the 100-year-old disaster actually came as the action game.
You can say that it is an apocalypse when burning this 0 dams.
Yes
, please next
. Since it is a well-matched series called Zelda Musou, it
is one of the pleasures of the saw series that there are many playable characters.  However,
this time, of course, various characters other than the link are also
playable. Well, as mentioned, it's four heroes, 100 years ago, so
what they actually lived and experienced is
drawn this time.  It's also drawn about their own feelings and such things
, and you can actually operate him as a playable and enjoy the action of
Hyrule Warriors.  Well this time, what kind of place is the Musou action?  As for the feature
, that link was always carried in the pressover world seekers
tone
This person has a unique action for the character.
Although there was a little in that video earlier, for example, the link is a remote control back.
If you mention the turn
, this time it's Maam,
so it's that person who is operating the lock that broke the handle, but that person only
uses items like this
[Music]
Buber  However, the reaction is completely different, isn't it? I'm unlucky and
each character is different. I hope you enjoy the action by
using the shaker saw arranged for winter depending on the type
.
Thank you.
Then, it was a part of history that could not be told 100 times so far, so there
was a little appearance in the movie of that part rhythm file,
but then I can see it firmly where I am fighting.
I'm really excited to be able to operate it as a fan.
Yes, Mr. Hayashi, that's right today. It means that you can strip off the actual play that will be released for the first time in the world.
This time
I used the link to
unveil the world premiere of the devilish play because I can't do it. Thank you. Yes
[Applause]
No, I think everyone was looking forward to it, but
one more guest is coming here.  Please come and
introduce yourself. Yes, I'm Koei Techmo Games Officer. Thank
you.
Well then, I'd like to see the actual machine play that will be released for the first time in the world from here.
Mr. and Mr. Matsushita
8 Well, I'll explain a little briefly before showing the playable, but
you can see the stage of the Hyral Plain at the beginning of the story
.
I'll show you the play on the link, but some
undisclosed characters will come out on the way. I bought meat and haven't
shown it yet.
I think I'll
take a look at this, so I'd like to show you the play that the old man has been practicing hard.
I'm going to show you while explaining, so let's go, please go home
.
It became a battle and shook the monsters of the disaster that rushed to the Hyrule Plains.
The ring bees of the Hyrule Kingdom stretched
out and were naked when they intercepted.
Consideration of a pawn shop who says that it is not a monster in cooperation with a race The monsters of the Self-Defense Force were able to be wiped out with a cannon, so Eva Majarin fans
who are going to create more Akanuma things from now on
Everyone else has submitted it, and it seems that the
situation is not good. I haven't been to the equipment, but it's
better to say that the exhibition was so unmatched.
Abe Character Action, isn't it?
Hyrule Each character has its
own character action, and if it's a link,
it's like breath of the wise. Yes, that's right, it's a
bow and arrow.
I think
yes. Yes, as you can see in the action of Link. Yes,
this work Link is old.
The picture of the state is put in before the disaster occurs
. There is a place like that square in the food with the army.
Well, that's just the beginning of the battle, it's
just the high city
ceiling.  Kit
Ah, let's show you the tour
[Music]
If you're not careful, I'm the
president, but
the battle with the small enemy isn't it?
I'm poking a gap
and I'm fluttering again There is also a Horiken dressing  I don't solo. Yeah, yeah, it's the
third straight victory. It wasn't fighting from the front, but it had a function. I'm
fighting while hoping that it's a counter
.
The exhilaration of this area is still
true.
Yes, it seems that the search for Zelda Musou is fun because there are people like that.
The feeling of the base is also the feeling of Zelda Musou or Musou
.
As you carry, the gauge of the base on the screen will increase
and you will have a powerful enemy at the end, so here the economy is
overwhelming the base.
You can cut 0 votes per day.
Hmm,
I'm Impa, who is the top of the nest of successful successors. I
didn't succeed at all in
Miha.
It
's a proof of compensation,
and I'm heading to the next battlefield.
I'm
heading to the next base
.
I
don't eat
more, I think I'm probably even more captain
.
That's right. After all, this was
the link that the world of Grace would take the most in the battle 100 years ago.
That's why I'm doing a mission to control the base that is on the right now
. It means that I've controlled one of them, right
?
Yes, it's a system similar to that of
Hyrule Warriors so far
.  ]
I'd like to ask you a lot, but I'm out of the hospital.
Open
Booburn I was worried about the beauty of the summer
.
The usual grace of the bell is a
little more weak, though.
I felt like I was pushing it to that kind of place, but
yes I'll forget the actual situation for a while. Maybe for
some reason c What is it like to use for gliding? Yes, now I'm using a
remote control bomb
to put Bob in.
Of course, it's already made.
Yes, it's okay to enter the end. It's
an action that allows you to create exchanges and connect with aerial
attacks. Let's do it over there.  I'm translating the force
while making full use of the book that asks you to change that as a character action
. I think the target is small,
but I think that the icon is just right.
Hmmm
[laughs]
I took a picture of the winter remote control bomb that is solidifying the guard, and the guard is said to be the guard.
On the other hand, we
say that it is because we accelerated the strong enemy like this.
I threw the rounds alternately and it was all I could do. It was
all-you-can-eat. I was
attacked by the link 100 years
ago.  It
's the arrangement of the sound of the world that I'm so excited
to see, and it's the most fun. With strong people.
Blue is the same as the face at that time
.
It was time to use these actions to fight using the designation and the
environment
. Mr. Sakai, that's right, I
couldn't help but he's a
little Kurobe-gumi.  I feel like I'm going to go beyond
this. If I could make this a student, it would be 2/3 suppression.
Also, there was a chance to counter the cat at any time
.
It seems that Saki Aso, who seems to be attacking, was able to succeed with one shot in the future, such as Saki Aso's own eyebrows
.  It's recommended to start at 0 o'clock immediately from there, but it's
a form of collecting cows.  That's right.
I'm told that I've become, but I'll switch to it, but even if I go home, it's a hobby.
It was listed like a character
, but 100 years ago it
was operated as a silver pan and imaged
[Music] In the
limp, zr coordination is like that child's action.
When you get it,
you're hearing
the minute sealer Yes, so please come again
Oh 3 e is a bullet-like
miso of the Seeker tribe, and it's
important right away
[Music]
xl There is no black
to go through me
Absorbing a little member will increase your alter ego. Your
life will increase a little, and you will be able to play and scrape the three-point gauge
. It's a scoop.
Well, it's about time for a melee 1 Is it around here?
1 I'd like to see it for a while, but before, it's a dog
up to this area
.
It's a place
where one person has increased. Yes, let's introduce that. I'm a
human. Yes, please.
I'm glad that the users found it,
but I think that it appeared as a role to guide the traveling around 100 years later with the chain character Impa, but
this time with the appearance of a lantern 100 years ago.  It's
the opposite of playing an active part in the art that you saw earlier and the physical art that you saw
earlier. It's said that the action is really different from the linq that I used at the beginning.
Yo  Since the action is returning now
, I think that you could see that the live is different even with that linked in pa, so
there are many abandoned village characters.
It's going to be a lot of fun.
Thank you for how you're fighting.
I'm sure you guys are saying it's fun. It's a good day, so
I was really happy to see the actual play.
I would like to introduce some new information on the apocalypse when burning dreams, which is Ethel
. What
will come out? Well,
actually, I also have the video that first appeared today.  I'm doing it, so
I'd like you to take a look at
it.
Link
I've grown tall again. The
rules do
n't change.
Ade face down I used it when I tried to use it
[Music] The
beast gave me
[Music]
I'll take care of it.
As long as
you don't let one step into the village of
Rito Egami Ah ah ah, let's show it now.  Rough Soul 6 Line
[Music]
Yes, how was the new
pv? No, that's exactly what you said in that comment.
Since
I was a musician, I could only say fragmentarily how the front hole etc. played an active part,
but this time I
wondered what happened to those four heroes 100 years ago.
This time,
you can see a part of it in the video this summer, where
you can actually experience what kind of
battle you had.  Everyone knew it, but there's something that looks like something in it, and I'm
really worried about how far it can be seen by spraying it.  It was pv
Yes, there is nothing in Fash Ward
Iyaha Yes, I hope you can support me by watching the video
.
There was a place, and there was an
influence on the use of pulling out pearls, but it was an up
campaign.
Yes
[Music]
[Laughs]
It was Buber Shirakusa.
Do you have an image of the God Beast shooting a beam
like this? It seems like it's far away.
Yeah
[laughs]
Boober I don't see Phoebe There are a few more things like this, but I
'll see them when I get home after the Buddha world
.  That's right because there is still information. Securities,
please. Yes, this is also the information that will be released for the first
time.
So, the Legend of Zelda: Breath Oza World Save data will be linked
.
Yes.
If you have the save data of Breath of the World,
the training soldier's tree described in
this work.  It's a gift for everyone
. Well, everyone will get it when the game is started for the first time.
Well, by all means with the lid of the pan, Nakano who said that
I want you to run around the world 100 years ago.
Is there something special or something that can be used for something? I've
mentioned it for a moment, but then that trainee and the prefecture's own weapons have good performance,
and that trainee is also ok.  So it's
a place where auto guards occur for people who are not good at action,
so it's a little easier to play.
On the contrary, this time I was doing this blues of the wild, but
it's the first time in the Musou series.
Not in the form of  Well, as the first trainer of the Warriors series,
I think it would be nice if you could equip it this time.
Some people
said that it wasn't there, so it's still about two months before it goes on sale. That's right. Why don't
you have
a breath?  I have a
sample of that item, so I managed to get the sample in time, so I actually had the real thing today, so
I hope you can see it.
Yes, that director Matsushita has this acrylic art
plate.
It's the packing art of the Apocalypse of Zelda Warriors
. It's an acrylic plate, so you can decorate it in your room
.
That's right, it shines a little depending on the angle of the sheet
. Yes, there is also a place where the theme is a little stinking
. Well
, it's a design that doesn't come.
That's why Matsushita is also keeping it upside down. It
's actually important in the example I wanted to come out earlier
. It's the one on the 9 o'clock side. Is this a good item
? This metal charm love
has another item with a paraf sale.  If you couldn't show much
with the blanket even with the previous action, it's a treasure box that also has
a high flanket of the number of sales after entering the sale breath of size
.
Yes,
this is really useless
[laugh]
I don't have one jab, but it's really useless as a star. Yes Thank you. Yes,
these three goods will be items in the treasure box
.  Since the quantity is limited
, I think that it may disappear when the release approaches, so if
you want it, it would be helpful if you could take the medicine as soon as possible.
I have
2 losses
. Finally,
let me introduce you to that release date and benefits.
Nintendo's switch-only software Hyrule Warriors Apocalypse is a,
then released on 10/11/20
.  The price of the package version download version is 7920 yen including tax. Yes, it's not two months left
.
Yes, it's okay. It's okay. It's okay. B Yes, thank you. 9 minutes
.  Limited edition treasure box with is also on sale on the same day as the release date
. Regarding the items, click here for the acrylic art plate
paracell style blanket metal charm that I just introduced. 3 items are included.
It hurts with the game software.  This person is the predecessor Nintendo store
gamecity Hyrule Warriors Amazon
We are planning to accept reservations and sell
at this person, so please take medicine at each site or shop of this
person.  The price of the person is 16,720 yen.
And next,
this is a store-specific privilege, and each store has various benefits as
described.  There is information about this person, isn't it? I'd like to upload
the image of that person as soon as the official homepage of that title is
available, so I'd like to consider purchasing at any store.
I hope everyone can choose if you can, so I'd like to
ask you next time
. It's a type of cultivation. Download Burn If you
make a reservation here,
this is the lucky
tamatu weapon.
Pink-san, this
is the place I'm equipping now. That raid The pot lid, the pot lid, and Abe that came out earlier are my two
favorites.
[Laughs]
This is a weapon that can use links.
It doesn't have to be equipped with the lid and 5 together, but
I wonder if this is better, so the south wind is this image.
I know it's
not like a brave man who can't enter anymore, but it
looks like this.
Yes, this is a boost item for strengthening the weapons of the grave.  Well, if you are the
download version, you can purchase this item as
a
privilege.
Yes
[Music]
I will do it later.  We have sent you the latest information on Kushiro Yoshi
.
Thank
you for your patience. Thank you.
Is it okay to say that it is full of highlights?
Yes, each of the left 4 concatenations really stands as a character, each has a different personality, and there are
various ways of fighting, so when making an action game,
I had to make a completely different action.  That's what I was big about,
why
was it the difference in actions like the one you saw in linked in pa
, or the difference in the action of seek items?
There are some actions that I haven't shown yet, so please look forward to it
. When I went for a walk to me, the Musou series was
pretty nice. I was doing other things, but the
previous work was Hyrule Warriors.  Well, I was wondering what to do with the same 6 respects,
but
the apocalypse of this disaster that blooms spicy is something more like the first Musou series, so it
's an atmosphere that is kind to people.
Well, I made it with a lot of consciousness, so I think that the
high press assistant Wild is a loss, but the Phildam layer is a game that even those who do not have such a thing
can play Yes
[Music]
Yes  But it's attached, is
n't it? No, I really want to listen to it. I have something I want to listen to.
But
there are many other things, right? That's
right, it's an example that made the user very distressed at the time of that Grace face of the wild,
or it was Murray's target.  Even
though it's a
matchless action, it's hard to get a tooth when you stick it straight in as it is,
so
if you manage to confront it with this kind of action or a new system, it
will be
chewy.
But I thought when I went with that ice cream earlier, but
the work of finding a part that is a little different from the way that Blazers Don was used like this
is also  I thought it would be fun to play with it.
Well, this is 0. I made it while communicating with
the members of the Turno Breath of Team.
This time, I experienced the world of breath 100 years ago.
I want you to experience it as an action game of the
army Gunter.
I want you to meet me, so even if you relate to the item action of c caste earlier,
the action of breath is not traced
as it is.  As a public match action, we developed it with the idea that by arranging it in this way, we
could create a world where the characters would be more attractive.
Yes,
I bought it when I saw pv for the first time.
I thought I was dropping it in the middle, so
when I did the Zelda Musou Arthur's previous work, it was a really expensive game that I bought for an action like walking in a park or in a
range
.  I thought that this work is very
bgm and the base part is very dress of the file,
but as you said,
the exhilarating part of the action is a very lie series.  Well, that's where I
really cherished the
legend of Zelda, where the legend of Zelda was dropped by Zelda Musou
.
After all, I experienced it so I can do it well here, so this
time I focused on learning 100 years ago from Breath and developed it.  I've come, so
I think I could have made this title this time because I had previous experience.
Yes, I
want everyone on the perla team to draw the two-car part and this brace like this.
I think I was able to make it dense even though I had a lot of opinions,
thank you. I think that there are still a lot of parts that you are not hungry for,
but let's wait together because there are not two months left.
Yes  So, I have sent you a lot of content, but the end time
is approaching ---
Finally, I would like to send a message to all of you,
Mr. Matsushita.
I think that the experience of Grace of the World has become a treasure for many people. I
think that everyone will surely enjoy it, so please wait a little longer until the release.
Thank you. Thank you.
[Applause]
Thank you.  Yes, as I've talked about many times before,
this time Breserve is wild, so
I think it's a living work, isn't it
?  That's why I had the Zelda team supervise it firmly
.
Probably the fifth work I also changed, but compared to the first work, it is tens of times more than 100 times
that custom.  I've been able to correct the feeling in every detail,
so I'd like the
Breath of the World fans to follow
me, not us, but the
Delzer team.  I'm wondering if I was able to get there,
so I hope you'll look forward to it. It's
only a few months left, but I hope you'll wait.
Thank you.
[Music]
Finally, Mr. Hayashi, please.
As I mentioned at the beginning, the development of this 100-year-old Hyrule Warriors tree proof
started when Mr. Aonuma of Nintendo talked about it, but in the
first place, I want you to enjoy the previous Hyrule Warriors as various character festival games.
And that's it  The character of Leeds was almost in a coordinated state.
I wondered if the title of Hyrule Warriors was over for us,
so let's talk about Mark and make such a wonderful title.  It was an opportunity for
everyone to do it. I think that it was completed in a way that meets expectations, so
I would like everyone to experience
it. What is it from now on?  I'd like to make such an interesting title, so I
played a game when I burned Hyrule Warriors. Actually, there is a live broadcast
from 5 o'clock, so it's also good there. I have
new information,
so please come tomorrow.
Thank you very much for your mission today. I'm really
looking forward to it as one of the fans. Then, the apocalypse when burning the Tokyo Game Show 2020 Hyrule Warriors
Special Nam Broadcasting is over.
Thank you everyone for watching until the end ---
Thank you very much
[Music]
I'm doing this